modern cognitive neuroscience tells us
that our memories are about as reliable
as a weatherman at your local news
channel when a couple is asked how did
you first meet they are lured into
romanticized reflection they might
recall locking eyes at a school dance
they might recall the night being just
perfect despite the truth being far from
it we don't remember the spilled punch
the stepped on toes or the st
stuttering we only remember the x's and
those
our memory doesn't find the needle by
sifting through the haystack but rather
by lighting a match and setting the barn
ablaze until all that remains is the
small piece of silver shining through
the smoke in this way our memories are
our best friends they know exactly when
to lie to us feeding us misinformation
about the past to satisfy ourselves in
the present because if humans were
capable of writing and recalling
accurate personal accounts of their
history our memories would be stiff
unmarketable literature and when a book
gets boring we tend to tap out just the
same when our lives get monotonous we
tend to give up so we have our faulty
biased brains to thank us for our
perceived happiness and fulfillment our
inaccurate memory systems consequently
help us hide trauma contrive purpose and
infuse unique importance into an
otherwise banal existence but let it be
known not all cerebral restructurings
are gifts from psychology some are
curses from scps which of these two
possibilities is more existentially
terrifying is up to you
scp-5040 is a non-existent japanese
horror film entitled tears of blood
which spontaneously manifests in human
memories
scp-5040 is a master of persuasion those
affected by scp-5040 will remember going
to see the film even when their supposed
attendance would contradict empirical
evidence it manipulates the mind into
unwavering faith while humans
occasionally stumble upon the
self-awareness to question their
recollection there are no documented
instances of an individual doubting this
specific memory somehow beyond the
foundation's understanding
scp-5040 manages to suspend the
skepticism of its victims they accept
the memory as canon as brute fact
victims of scp-5040 do not need a ticket
stop to know they have been to the
theater and scp-5040 afflictions can
occur any place where movies are shown
it even transcends laws and navigates
social norms in cultures where its
content would usually be prohibited by
regulations and frowned upon by the
public it still inserts itself into the
memory of its prey and once that memory
is planted it's an event that can't be
forgotten like the birth of your first
child like your favorite football team
winning the super bowl like the employee
number you punch in and out of work
every day for the rest of your life it
stamps itself into the forefront of the
subject's brain waving its arm pleading
to be recognized begging for attention
descriptions of the film are always
similar in nature as are the
circumstances and events surrounding the
viewing however reports of scp-5040's
story and characters are never fully
consistent from one subject to the next
and the film's setting subplots
character names and much of the dialogue
are different for each viewer whether
this is
scp-5040's intent or inadequacy is
unclear casting also varies and appears
largely arbitrary a broad variety of
japanese performers and entertainment
personalities both living and deceased
have been said to star in the film even
when the actor in question has no real
life associations with the horror genre
imagine famous japanese actor pat morita
better known as mr miyagi from the
karate kid being the lead in a horror
film despite the fact this would be a
noticeably strange casting decision
scp-5040 would still be taken seriously
despite any and all deviations from
expectations of the medium
scp-5040 is seen as legitimate kinks in
its design are overlooked by the viewer
similar to how our sleeping selves most
often don't recognize we are dreaming
even when we encounter flying horses
friends with banana fingers and
leprechauns playing pot limit omaha in
chris hemsworth's basement this may be
because despite all of its quirks the
film's core is sturdy its beginning
middle and end are always in agreement
it doesn't stray from robert mckee's
universal structure of story not even
the sick twisted m night shyamalan
himself could have created a cinematic
experience quite like this after
conducting more than 300 interviews
researchers have constructed a detailed
synopsis of scp-5040's most consistent
story elements and the most common
sequence of events associated with the
viewer's memory of their screening
attendance there is no matinee with this
movie screenings always begin at sunset
if there are obstacles standing in the
way of the subject's attendance
scp-5040 will see them removed dentist
appointments drinks with a friend a long
procrastinated date with the treadmill
all these commitments for that day and
time will be pushed down the subject's
list of priorities making way for the
movie they will learn that their plans
have been cancelled or resolved one way
or another the dentist's office burned
to the ground your friend is suddenly
sober the model of treadmills at your
gym have been recalled somehow some way
time is freed up and when life is kind
enough to offer respite from personal
and social obligations it is modern
humans instinct to sit down and veg out
at this moment the subjects decide to
see a movie at a nearby theater upon
arrival the theater looks to be an
entity in its own right long lines of
patrons are like limbs extending from
its center box office bright blocky
letters forming the film's title run
across the marquee like a cheap tattoo
it is truly madness a frenzied crowd
gathers at the box office pushing and
shoving clawing at the glass partition
for a ticket the entire theater has been
reserved for this special event a
one-time only screening of a rare
critically acclaimed film admission is
entirely free but is it actually free or
has the cost just not declared itself
when the subject reaches the auditorium
they scan their eyes over the sea of
people heads emerge from the backs of
almost every seat they can only find one
empty space and they have to shuffle
like a crab to get past the mass of
other viewers in their seat they notice
that a large number of people throughout
the audience are wearing disposable face
masks the woman sitting next to the
subject's right wears one such mask as
does the woman on their left and before
you think well that isn't so weird it's
important to note that all of these
accounts were taken years before certain
recent events patrons continue to pack
into the theater despite every chair
being filled more and more people enter
the aisles become overflow seating
regulations of max occupancy are
dismissed in the darkness of the room
all that can be clearly seen are shapes
the rectangle that is the screen the
hundreds of circles that are the heads
of the audience but there is a shape
that feels misplaced what appears to be
the letter p sticks up from the crowd a
thin line with a bulge protruding from
the top the specificity of its origin is
difficult to define but once the
subject's eyes adjust to the dark they
notice it's an iv pole carrying a bag of
unknown fluid however there is no clear
indication of who it is connected to
furthermore they notice one of the
masked audience members is wearing a
hospital gown there is little time to
assess any of these strange visuals
because there are no trailers or
advertisements before the film as soon
as the audience is settled into whatever
space they might find temporarily
habitable the theater goes silent and
the film begins the film opens with a
female protagonist going about mundane
activities in her day-to-day life a
phone call interrupts her it is an
unknown party who tells her that a loved
one has been hospitalized for one reason
or another the protagonist drops what
she's doing to accept the call to action
on her way to the hospital however she
is attacked by a male assailant and
loses consciousness the protagonist
wakes up in a fog unable to make sense
of her surroundings but the audience
understands that wherever she is she is
in deep trouble she's in a desolate and
unfamiliar building with her arms and
legs bound she is accompanied by a
number of other female captives some of
whom still remain seemingly unconscious
or possibly dead the woman briefly
discussed their strategy to escape but
they are interrupted when the kidnapper
appears descriptions of hairstyle eye
color and wardrobe would fall short in
showing us who this character really is
instead his swift and decisive actions
do the talking he sees one of the woman
crying and kills her without hesitation
the kidnapper reveals to the woman the
code he intended to operate under he
would release the captives after 24
hours but only under the condition that
they do not cry during the film the
kidnapper demonstrates various forms of
physical and psychological torture on
the group of women despite their best
efforts the captives are unable to hold
back their tears and one by one they are
murdered until only the protagonist
remains frustrated by the protagonist's
unremarkable resolve the kidnapper takes
more extreme measures increasing
intensity of her torture however the
protagonist is not one to be messed with
despite being tormented she seems in
control of the situation she doesn't
succumb to the traditional dynamics of
torture even while on the wrong end of
the bat she isn't afraid to swing she
fights back how she can she mocks and
insults her captor and it's then she
finds his weakness although a physically
empowering villain he is emotionally
fragile
her grit frustrates him causing him to
lose focus and become noticeably rattled
as the protagonist continues to weaken
her kidnapper with words the subject in
the audience notices what seems to be a
slight echo in the dialogue they look up
to see if something is wrong with the
speakers they even wonder if this is a
stylistic decision made by the director
but then they notice where it is coming
from they eventually realize that the
two masked women sitting beside them are
quietly repeating every line of dialogue
as it occurs their lips moving causes
their masks to shake softly with each
word the air from their whispers blows
the cloth away from their mouth only for
the mask to collapse back in when the
syllable is completed if the subject
looks even closer they will see that the
lower half of the women's masks are
saturated with saliva things don't get
any more pleasant when the subject
shifts their gaze down the woman's body
just near their waists their hands are
clasped together so tightly that their
fingernails are digging into their skin
they tremble and fidget as if having
taken on the burden of the world's
anxiety and no medication can calm them
down fingernails dig deeper into their
skin drawing blood and foreshadowing the
film's finale at the film's climax the
kidnapper approaches the protagonist
with a double-edged razor blade and
announces that even if she is freed she
will spend the rest of her life horribly
disfigured this leads to an argument
between the two the subtext of which
alludes to themes such as nature of
inner and outer beauty the value of
women in society and the societal stigma
against expressions of vulnerability the
argument on the surface however does not
sound sophisticated or profound there is
no consolation for a fight having
emotional depths at the end of the day
the blows will always feel more physical
than intellectual eventually the
kidnapper loses patience and grabs the
protagonist by the shoulders and slams
her to the floor he reaches out his
hands and grabs her by the face the
subject's attention is again pulled from
the screen when they hear groaning from
every direction the wordless hums filled
the theater with a sense of worry and
uneasiness so much so that the subject
feels the room getting smaller as the
air polluted with angst grows thicker as
the subject brings their eyes back to
the film they see the kidnapper gripping
the protagonist's lower lip between his
thumb and forefinger squeezing tight as
to pop her lip like a balloon the
kidnapper then takes the razor blade to
the victim's lips he pauses to mock the
protagonist and while he does this
blinded by pride and arrogance she jolts
into action grabbing the razor right out
of his hands with her teeth she follows
up her burglary with assault her neck
stabs forward and in a blur she stabs
the kidnapper's eyes out it happens in
an instant the kidnapper has no time to
react blood spills from his face screams
pour out of his mouth during this time
the protagonist maneuvers the razor into
her fingers she hacks away at her
bindings but they are stubborn and
resist her sawing the battle continues
and the kidnapper is able to tear off
the victim's lips entirely she looks
like a monster now as the kidnapper
smiles and celebrates his wrongdoings
the protagonist finishes freeing herself
and slits the kidnapper's throat with
the razor the protagonist locates the
exit and scrambles towards it as the
kidnapper bleeds to death on the cold
hard floor the protagonist then speaks
her final words due to her injuries her
voice is muffled and raspy she bears
down and calmly speaks one last time she
mocks the kidnapper telling him that he
cried tears of blood and therefore had
to die according to his own rules
during this climax it is reported that
the subjects experience a sense of dread
unique to any other terror ever felt
strangely the feeling appeared not to
correspond to the scene in the film at
all it is a feeling entirely separate
from the viewing experience as if for a
moment the subject is taken out of the
moment in time and transported to a
realm composed only of fear and anxiety
but just as quickly as they left they
returned the foundation sees it worth
mentioning that this peculiar moment
happens to occur during the film's most
clearly recalled scene while
descriptions of violence vary from one
viewer to the next the climax is
unshakable in its consistency this is
further evidence that scp-5040 has a
core foundation that remains intact
false memories are given validity by our
peers when we tell a story the
inaccuracies are often the best parts
the exaggerated drama the rearranged
sequence of events the jokes you thought
of in retrospect but weaved into later
accounts while a storyteller knows when
to lie a good storyteller knows how to
not get caught
scp-5040 captivates its audience but it
seems to know how much it can get away
with by providing a consistent objective
truth a climax that is reported the same
across all accounts scp-5040
insists even if only briefly on being a
credible film not just a random sequence
of 24 frames per second eyes back to the
screen the film abruptly cuts to an
unspecified point in the future now
wearing a face mask to hide her
disfigured mouth no different than the
one seen worn in the theater the
protagonist walks down the street to her
apartment indifferent to the crowd of
paparazzi that follows her it is clear
that this is now just a part of her life
the lights flash on her face when she
reaches her bedroom the protagonist
slowly pulls down her mask face-free
from cloth she stares at herself in the
mirror it is silent what she sees is
less notable than what she doesn't the
lower portion of her face is gone she
focuses only on that it's hard to know
if she will ever see into her own eyes
again her gaze might forever be fixed on
what she can't get back and through
those eyes that long to see more she
sheds a single tear over the course of
several minutes her weeping gradually
builds into frenzied sobs and shrieks it
can first be misinterpreted as bad
acting a case of doing too much but as
the crying carries onward it's
understood that the horror in her
wallowing is all too real the film cuts
to black and the credits roll but the
sound of the protagonist's cries
continue to play with no other audio
until the credit reel ends and even then
in silence it's hard to say if she ever
stopped crying audience members remain
silent after the movie ends exchanging
only whispers as they exit the theater
feet step over small red puddles and
stains on the theater floor as if they
are sticky puddles of soda those who
remain past this point experience an
escalating feeling of unwelcomeness
until sitting and staying is more
physically demanding than getting up and
walking out some experiences will stay
with you forever
even if they never actually happened now
go check out scp-592
inaccurate history book and scp-2030
laugh is fun for more media that'll
stick in your brain forever